okay so this is my spoiler review of
mind hunter season 2 so jumping into
this
I'm always when I'm watching mine hunter
a show like this I'm always wondering
okay the big director of this show
always is David Fincher how many
episodes does Fincher gonna do so I
always sit through the credits to see
who's gonna be behind the camera here
and Fincher does episode 1 2 and 3 and
disappointingly he did not do the finale
this time which was strange to me I'm
usually the big director in a series
does at least the opener in the finale
so you could tell a little downside and
quality in the finale in my opinion
there and I think that's a result of
that but jumping into this with this
season it's such a strange feeling I got
watching the season of mine hunter
because episodes 1 through 5 were
majestic and I mean I was just in heaven
I loved it I thought it was some of the
best television I've ever seen and what
it did was the beginning was really good
at writing all these characters and
making so much sense of what they were
saying from their perspective whether it
was from Wendie referencing stuff about
homosexuality and those little meanings
I'd have from her experiences but they
don't know she's that and same with
built in talking about just children and
how oh you got to give a break to
someone when they're younger thinking
about his son so they did a really good
job with that and if season one was
about Holden Ford season two was more
about built in ch and I liked that I
think that was really cool because the
actor of built n CH Holtz McElhaney
really stepped it up here he was awesome
he is a treat to watch and he also has
great comedic timing as well I think he
can go as one of those people who his
character build tension is one of the
most likeable characters I've seen in a
show to date so that's always a treat
and what makes this show always strong
is that you have three strong leads in
Jonathan Groff Anna Torv
and Halton McElhaney now what ended up
happening here was to me
episode 2 & 5 were excellent 2 being
really good and 5 being an absolute
masterpiece now it's kind of expecting
his episode to hit Son of Sam
episode 5 had Manson and a surprise with
adding text in there which I thought was
awesome and it was really weird about it
it was it almost felt like a follow-up
to Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
especially because the same actor who
plays Charles Manson in both but that
did not disappoint and they hyped it up
well in the show itself the whole Manson
thing and it really was great now it
felt so weird cuz it was like you had
the best moments of the season there and
then once episode 6 through 9 happened
and they solely focused on the Atlanta
story it lost a little bit of feeling
like mine hunter it felt like a good
crime TV show it felt like a season of
true detective
it's good it's good at doing that but it
was like is this the same show I just
watched in the first half of the season
cuz it just completely shifted how it
kind of runs things and I don't think it
was super effective because there's so
many shows like that and what made mine
hunter stand out from the rest was it
was unique in the whole interview aspect
and that's when it's the strongest now
it was really good in season 1 getting
us into the mind of Ford and this season
was more about bill 10 and Wendy but
Wendy story fell flat and built inches
story about his son was way too much
screentime like they kept going back to
the wife and the kid a lot and it was
kind of just beating a dead horse like
constantly reminding us the mother state
of mind and yeah I get it that it was
gonna end with oh my god Bill's so
focused on his job and he's losing his
family and he knows that in the end and
then ends up happening but it was kind
of repeating itself in a way and just
too much of it where it was just kind of
becoming a little too heavy on the
characters and that could also take away
when you're doing that too much
especially it's not the most interesting
stuff which it really wasn't
and especially with Wendy's story I mean
that was a cut-and-paste love story from
anything you've seen a hundred times
over especially with the kid and then
her exiting the other door and it didn't
feel owned the moment with them in the
phone booth because it was actually as
slow as her story was was also really
rushed in the timeline of things for the
viewer it was like wait whoa wait
they're already this serious and also
and they're already talking about why
they can't be together anymore and it
didn't even get a chance to breathe and
develop that love so I thought that was
really weak and it was really weird that
they just ended it there with Wendy and
I thought the first couple episodes
built up really well Wendy and agent
Smith the fourth wheel here because they
started doing interviews which I thought
was perfect for their characters and I
think it gave Wendy something more to do
and then they just completely dropped
that and went towards her backstory and
Agent Smith disappeared that also
includes the boss so the new boss gun I
really liked his addition to this cast
because I think he was a great
centerpiece to see how everyone reacts
around someone like him and it was
bringing out better character moments of
everybody and this like looming
mysterious man we didn't really know his
intentions which is that was very
interesting but they ditched him too I
mean that was built up well especially
was telling Wendy like he doesn't want
her doing interviews and he was creepy
towards at the party so they kind of
just ditched it and it felt like I don't
know just like the rug was pulled
beneath those storylines had developed
in the beginning and just fully went
into Atlanta now it wasn't that Alana
was bad it was still good and I mean
there was brilliant moments especially
when Ford is talking to the Atlanta
monster in his living room that was a
really standout scene for me when they
found him at the bridge it was very
exciting but again it just felt like you
just were getting a different show and
not what you were kind of sold on in the
beginning and that almost I would
suggest as someone other than how much
time to watch a lot of things just watch
one through five and I think Atlanta
being a true story obviously it's not
the most exciting way it ends and kind
of just ends where they get them but
there's not super justice there and
we've again seen those kind of like
that's it story endings and that's one
of those cases and you obviously can't
change its history but why make that the
whole second half of the season it just
doesn't make any sense to me and I
thought at least
with the atlanta monster we'd get like a
legit interview into his psyche by Ford
and tench and we did not yes they were
question him at the end but it still
wasn't that my hunter esque field and
that was really the whole point of this
show and just kind of became a goose
chase so that was really strange to me
but I actually would say besides the
Manson and Son of Sam scenes I'd argue
even the best scene of this season was
in the episode where actually they're
hitting on the BTK killer which are
always showing the beginning since
season one when tench is talking to the
boy who was shot by him but survived a
beat DK scenario and when he's in the
back seat that was like really just
amazing acting by Halton McElhaney
because that's like any worthy stuff and
that's seen just having an edge of my
seat and that's what I'm talking about
we're like to rate this season you could
see on a site like Rotten Tomatoes right
it's got 100% 900 season - is it deserve
that hell no but you might say that from
the first five episodes but the problem
is when they send these screeners out
you know these critics they're reviewing
so much stuff they didn't have time to
watch the whole season yet especially
because they didn't send out to a lot of
press the screeners for mine hunters so
they're watching the first three four
episodes and I'll probably go this is
great given it a hundred but that's not
representative of the actual what
happened in this season it's kind of
like masks it's such a good top that the
reviews came out great but if you
actually dig into their reviews if
people watch the whole season I think
most are on the same page or I mean
that's what I felt like the second half
was just really disappointing and when
you're rating it's tough because I look
at the first half and think it's just
masterful and then the second half is
just dull so - wait it's got to bring
points down right so and then I have to
compare it in my head to season one
because that's what we do with shows
right with seasons and season one I gave
a 9 in my review you can check that
review out this season I'm actually
gonna give it an eight point nine
because just because I really thought I
was like oh yeah I was sold seasons
who's way better than season one and
half way through and then six and seven
drag removing like whatever it's gonna
happen but then it was a little bit of a
letdown the last two episodes as well
because like we're still in Atlanta here
we're
still just doing this and really nothing
else in this weird Wendy stories just
kind of not connecting to the plot well
and I don't know I thought that was
really weird and yeah and I I'm sure
people I feel like it's polarizing the
whole kid thing because it's a little
like the omen and it's again I think any
time you bring in shows like a kid and
give them too much screen time and it
wasn't started off with that in the show
it's dangerous waters I think it always
can just get people little like ah you
know and like a show like bloodline when
I had the kid in season two in a kind of
drop-down I don't know many times when
you add a kid as a spotlight and it
brings a show up it's very rare it's
hard to do unless it's already a show or
movie that's centered around the kids
and that's establish from the beginning
so that was frustrating I think I'm just
seeing a lot of shows now if you watch
my Hammond till review I say the same
thing we're like there's this weird
thing going on when there's so many
shows coming out and it feels like
there's a disconnect from episode to
episode and I feel like that for this
show just happened from first half the
second half like it just felt like a
different show and I I just I'm so
curious why that keeps happening
recently and I don't know if it's just I
would say it's usually because of time
and rushing but this is two years ago
ating for this to come back so it's a
little disappointed to just kind of go
the lazy route the second half and you
had some gold they were setting up I
mean that BTK stuff's really interesting
too and I get then we're gonna go on
Manson and that's fine I didn't expect
that but maybe give another scene or two
about BTK from the detectives
perspectives maybe give us just a little
bit of backstory about hold him again I
know we had the main spotlight last
season but he is still the most
interesting character and to not
progress his character that much at all
this season is really super
disappointing because he is our main
character and I just wonder like okay so
what are gonna wait another two years
and then what like now what shows are
gonna be is it gonna be interviews or
are we gonna just have true detective
2.0 like so that's that's frustrating
but again I'm gonna give it an eight
point nine it still doesn't take away
from how at the beginning was you have
to give props to that and again episode
5 and 2
top to bottom just what a treat so let
me know you thought this one down below
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
one and please follow me at Steve are
they wanted Twitter Instagram for more
of me and please make sure to subscribe
I do a bunch of shows movie reviews and
interviews with celebrities themselves
and make sure to give this a like and
I'll see you next time